nonetheless the standard for the media
it's new it's a new standard the media
are overt partisans on behalf of joe
biden it is insane
nbc news reporter ben collins he
actually tweeted out
reminder for your uncle the press can't
cover hunter's hard drive because we
don't have access to it this isn't a
wikileaks thing one guy has access to it
he wouldn't give it to us now he's in
quasi-hiding because he got caught
in a hotel room with borat's daughter
right talking about rudy giuliani not
turning over the hard drive
to nbc for example but weird because i
don't remember you having any access to
any of the underlying material in nearly
any of the stories you've reported about
russiagate for literally years on end
so the standard is magically morphing it
is magically changing
my favorite line of the weekend actually
came courtesy
of thomas ridd a professor of strategic
studies at johns hopkins university
school of advanced international studies
he had a piece in the washington post
this is a direct quote you ready we must
treat the hunter biden leaks as if they
were a foreign intelligence operation
even if they probably aren't even if
they probably aren't so now
we have to just ignore them and not
report on them even if they're legit
because we have to work under the
assumption that anything said bad about
democrats must be russian disinformation
all of which allows joe biden to simply
treat reporters like garbage when he's
asked about it here was joe biden over
the weekend
being asked about hunter biden and just
cutting him dead
questions the controversy continues
today about under buying your sons
there is no controversy about my son
it's all a lie it's a flat lie because
the president has nothing
else to run on if you notice and while
american people are talking about what's
happening to their families
he has no plan and the debate he has no
plan everything from the wall street
journal
every other major news outlet has said
what he's
saying is simply not true about my son
but it's
it's classic trump classic trump
okay except for the fact that um
actually the emails are real
and the texts are real and people are
asking legit questions about them but
the good news is he can just shout
coveted masks
and everybody goes oh well he knows the
solution guys everything will be better
tomorrow if that evil malevolent force
donald trump
is out of office again all this also
allows joe biden to escape from the fact
that
he is not with it okay now he can get
he's not to say he can't get through a
sentence he can get through a sentence
and get through several sentences he
can't get through like a full paragraph
without starting to lose it
okay over the weekend over and over and
over joe biden was just gaffing all over
the place now one of these gaffes
would have killed any other candidate
seriously
any other count mitt romney you remember
what about your gaffes people
yelling at mitt romney as though mitt
romney were half as senile as joe biden
appears to be on the verge of being
okay i'm old enough to remember when
people took gaffes seriously so long as
they were coming from republicans
i mean we still remember all of george w
bush's guests right edumacation
remember that one edumacation we still
remember dan quayle misspelling potato
right these were major gaffes
joe biden mixes up which office he is
running for he mixes up which state he
is in
he mixes up the candidate he is running
against over the weekend
he suggested he was running against
george i assume he means bush not george
or the jungle
but guess what bush has been out of
office since 2008. here is biden
mistaking trump for bush this is the
most consequent not because i'm running
but because who i'm running against it's
the most consequential election
uh in a long long long time
and the character of the country in my
view is literally on the ballot
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh is going to find ourselves
in a position where
if trump gets elected we're going to be
we're going to be in a different world
that wasn't the only one then joe biden
bragged about having the most expensive
voter fraud organization in history
again these are these are gafs that
would any other candidate these would
all be headlines
but it's protect the precious time now
right we're in the final days of the
election protect the precious even if
that precious
is a daughter and coot who's not going
to be in office for four years let alone
eight
here's joe biden we're in a situation
where
we have put together and you guys
did it for our administer the president
obama's administration
before this we have put together i think
the most
extensive and inclusive voter fraud
organization in the history of american
politics
that's exciting he's put together the
most extensive voter fraud organization
in the history of american politics
you want to get those conspiracy
theorists going that would be the way
that you do it
and again the good news is that for the
democrats
nobody is going to ever ever have to
answer a tough question because they're
democrats
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content